Strange looking place.
What I thought.
Fuel pump.
How long you think
it'll take you to fix?
Has to be replaced.
Take about a half an hour
if they have the part.
Hm.
They should have one with
all these wrecks around here.
This back highway's good for
time, but have car trouble
and you've got problems.
If it had to happen, I'm
glad it happened where it did
and when it did.
I didn't much relish the idea of
being stuck on those mountains.
I'd say we're lucky.
Another few miles, we'd
have been in desert.
Is it what you
thought, Mr. Stiles?
I'm afraid so.
Can we still make the game?
Oh, we got 40 miles to go.
12:01.
Game doesn't start 'til 1:30.
We can still make it
if they have the part.
And if they don't?
It's plain stuck.
If it wasn't Sunday, they
could order one from Lancaster.
Where are the people
who run this place?
Hello?
You see, when the
player swats the ball--
Not swats the ball, Doris.
Bats.
The player bats the ball.
Yeah.
When the player bats the ball
and it goes over the fence--
That's a home run.
I know.
But if no one can
make him out, why
does he have to run
around the bases?
Because he has to.
That's the rules.
He must touch every base.
Would you like a Coke?
Oh, thank you.
Somebody can run off
with the whole place
and the owner would
never know it.
Coke, Ed?
Sure.
From the looks
of things, nothing
'round here worth taking.
It's a wonder they get
any business at all.
Everything is so
dirty and greasy.
All work isn't white
collar work, Miss Page.
I was in the Army.
I had my fill of
this repairing tanks.
Miss Prim and Proper
should have known me then.
Doris Page is a sweet girl,
Ed, and a good math teacher.
Uh, a little on the
prudish side, perhaps.
A boy in my phys ed class
calls her Miss Ice Buckets.
Mr. Oliver, I think
theirs is a, a silly rule.
There is no reason why a man
should have to run around
the bases when they
can't get him out.
Isn't that a woman for you?
Never seen a baseball
game and already
she's changing the rules.
You should go to a
ball game with my wife.
Well, I still think
that's a silly rule.
We're never going to
see any baseball today.
Where's the guy that
runs this place?
Hey, what about some service?
Hello?
They must be around
here some place.
Doesn't seem likely
they'd go away
and leave everything wide open.
Perhaps they're around
in back some place.
Hey, anybody here?
Hello?
If the pump hadn't already
been stripped off that Chevy,
we might be in business.
We got ourselves a fuel
pump if it's any good.
Will that work on our car?
Take a few adjustments,
but should get us to LA.
I'll borrow a few wrenches,
and we'll soon be out of here.
Our Mr. Stiles
has many talents.
A fine young man.
Be a lucky woman that hooks him.
Oh, Mr. Oliver, I do believe
you're playing Cupid again.
You're only young
once, Miss Page.
Why, Mr. Oliver, you
sound like an old man.
Well, 52 yesterday.
I'd say you'd had a
fine and full life.
A nice home, a lovely wife,
two handsome children.
Carl Junior graduates from
West Point in two weeks.
Wife and I are going
back for the graduation.
This guy really takes
care of his tools.
Hm.
Wonder where these people are.
I'll look around and see
if I can find somebody.
I don't want to
shock you, Miss Page,
but I'd rather not
get my shirt dirty.
Oh really, Mr. Stiles,
I'm not that stuffy.
I don't know.
We've taught the same
school for over a year
and it's still Miss
Page and Mr. Stiles.
I do think Ed and Doris
would sound a lot better.
From now on it shall
be Ed and Doris.
Just a snake skin.
They shed this time of year.
I can't stand snakes.
Most people can't.
Part of the country's
loaded with them, big ones.
I hear they get to be as
much as nine feet long.
Well, I was certainly
wrong, wasn't I?
Hello?
Anybody here?
Doris?
Ed?
Hello?
You'd never know
he's the same history
teacher from old Lancaster High.
He really cuts loose.
Today he'll really be in
this glory with his red flag.
I know.
Edna told me last night
that he hasn't seen them
play since they left Cincinnati.
She said ever since he got
the tickets he's been--
There's something going on
here that just isn't right.
Settings were four at the
kitchen table, two plates eaten
from and two plates
untouched, pie still warm.
Except for a cat there's
not a sign of life.
The sooner we get out of here,
the better off I'll feel.
Just keep working,
mister, because you're
going to fix your car
just like you intended.
Young man, you have
no right to take our--
Shut up.
What if I don't fix it?
You'll fix it
all right, mister.
You better not take
too long, either.
Supposing I get it
fixed, what happens then?
Me and my girl go away
and won't bother you.
Ah, ah,
ah, ah, ah, ah.
How do we know
you'll keep your word?
Looks like you're just going to
have take it, ain'tcha, mister?
Bang!
You, give me your wallet.
There's not much, but
you're welcome to it.
Well, we're only
schoolteachers, young man.
You hear that, Judy?
"We're only schoolteachers."
We don't like
schoolteachers, do we, Judy?
Teachers think they're so much
smarter than everybody else.
You have our money.
Isn't that enough?
What else do you want?
Just keep
working, mister.
Teachers used to call
Judy dumb, make fun of her,
send her home from
school crying.
No!
Stop it!
You're a pretty good size, boy.
I wonder how tough you'd
be without that gun.
Ooh, you're one
of them real big talkers,
ain't you, mister?
All right, big talker,
hand over your wallet.
Come on.
Pick it up.
You pick it up.
You're a real big man in
front of your lady friend.
But I'm going to show her
just how big you really are.
Put down that gun and I'll
show you how big you are.
I'm giving you three seconds,
mister, to do what I say.
I'm saying you pick
up that wallet.
One, two.
Please, do as he says.
Uh, you
put on the fender.
Or do you want the gun, huh?
You want the gun?
On the fender.
Big man, huh?
I guess you got showed
how big you really was.
Start working.
May I get some water?
This poor man has been
blinded by his own blood.
Don't you even have the decency
to let me care for this man?
What kind of a person are you?
Do you enjoy hurting
others, seeing them in pain?
How can you be so inhuman?
Eh, uh, uh uh, uh.
How is he?
His head is all right,
but I know it must hurt.
The gash in his cheek
isn't too, too bad,
but the cut over his eye,
it won't stop bleeding.
I'm afraid he might
bleed to death.
Now, now, Doris, it
can't be that bad.
Where do you
think you're going?
This man needs
help, and he's going
to get it if you
want this car fixed.
He's going to be
all right, Doris.
You're lucky, Carl.
A little more to the right
you wouldn't be here.
If we can get you some
water and in the shade
we can stop the bleeding.
What about letting this
man get in the shade?
How can you be so cruel?
You get back in that car, and
he won't be needing nothing.
Oh, by all means,
enjoy your lovemaking.
Well, the least
you can do is allow
a suffering man a little water.
Carrying on like that when--
you're no more than an animal!
You get your dirty hands off me.
You leave her alone if
you want the car fixed.
And he won't fix it unless
you let us get some water.
There's a pump by the house.
You keep working
on that car, mister.
And you, go ahead.
Shoot if they move, Judy.
If I hear a shot, your
girlfriend is dead.
Don't get no ideas.
Judy don't know
how to use a gun.
I wonder, I wonder why
he changed his mind.
Ed, I don't like this.
I know something else
you won't like, Carl.
Remember reading last week
about those brutal killings
in Arizona?
Will you please let me by?
Why are you putting us
through this torture?
You have our money and
you're taking our car.
Isn't that enough?
You keep your
dirty hands off me.
You think your so
much better than me.
Your kind all think that way.
You called me inhuman.
All right.
I apologize.
I shouldn't have said that.
Now, will you let me go?
Called me an animal.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry I said those things.
Now, can I go?
You're sorry, but
you still think it.
You think I'm dirt.
You think Judy's dirt.
You'll always think it 'til
you don't think no more.
Your kind means
nothing, you hear?
Nothing.
Why don't you scream?
Maybe the big talker
will come and help you.
Maybe Miss Goodie
Good Good still
thinks she's so
much better than me.
How does it feel to be
touched by dirt, huh?
Goodie Good Good don't like it.
Taste it.
Taste it!
Eat the dirt.
Taste it.
Miss Goodie Good don't think
she's so much now, does she?
She don't mind being
touched by dirt.
Get moving.
What did he do to you, child?
It's all right, Mr. Oliver.
It's all right.
Get back to work.
You want that car fixed,
you can do it yourself.
Starting to be the
big man again, huh?
You're the big man, Tibbs.
That's the name, isn't it?
Charlie Tibbs?
The big man who
killed seven people.
Made them get on their knees
and shot them in the head.
The paper calls you
a thrill killer.
Must be a real thrill to
wipe out a family of five.
How many thrills have you
had since you left Arizona?
What about the people here?
Did you kill them too?
How long do you
think you could keep
getting away with this, son?
The law's bound to catch up
with you sooner or later.
And the law has ways
of handling murderers.
Please don't
antagonize him any more.
What's going to happen to you?
Anybody opens
their mouth again,
I'll blow their brains out.
Listen, big man, you get
back to fixing that car,
or you're going to be
a big dead man fast.
All of a sudden
everybody's becoming
the big talker,
getting kind of brave.
Nobody wants to
talk no more, Judy.
I'm going
to get my goodie bag.
Judy, bring me a soda.
Just a little target practice.
I'm going to shake
the bottle over
head.
Mr. Oliver, they're going
to do something terrible,
I just know it.
You, get up.
Over there.
What are you going to do?
Shut up.
Move!
That's far enough.
Down on your knees.
On your knees!
Seeing as how you like to
talk, go ahead and talk.
Talk all you want.
As soon as I finish this, you
going to be through talking.
School be out for you, teacher.
You better start
talking, mister.
Your time's running out.
You can't shoot me like this
for no reason, for nothing.
Surely blowing my head off
can't give you a thrill.
Is it money you need?
I have close to
$2,300 in the bank.
Tomorrow you can call my wife.
She'll give it to
you, all of it.
You and your girlfriend can
have a lot of fun on $2,300.
He sure is talking
a lot different
than he did a while
ago, ain't he, Judy?
You have a father, don't you?
Would you want someone
doing this to him?
Think of your own father
in my place, or yours.
Save your
breath on her, mister.
I'm the only thing
in the world she has.
Her old man's dead, and
her old lady's a drunk.
Young lady, can't you
realize this is wrong?
You love him, don't you?
You know what it is to be
around someone you love
and who loves you?
I have loved ones too, a
daughter a little older
than you, a son about his age.
Please, I beg of you,
talk to your boyfriend.
Tell him this is wrong.
Tell him, please.
My god, child, haven't
you any feelings at all?
Can't you understand?
Look at him squirm, Judy.
They're all alike, ain't they?
Yellow when they go.
You just can't wipe out a man's
life like this, not like this.
We just can't stand
here and watch.
Ed, you can't let him do this.
Maybe he'll listen to you.
Talk to him.
Ed, talk to him.
Make
somebody do something.
Tell him you won't fix the car.
Don't let him do it.
You want the car fixed?
Maybe the big man wants
to take your place.
He says one more word, he will.
What about it, big man.
You feel like talking?
Maybe Miss Good Good
wants to take his place.
I guess nobody wants to
take your place, mister.
School's out, teacher.
No.
No, please.
Don't.
Ed, Miss Page.
You
monster, you monster!
Doris, Doris.
Go ahead, do it.
Shut up.
Shut up yourself.
Doris, get control of yourself.
And you, you coward.
Doris!
Don't touch me.
Doris, you're going
to get us both shot.
I don't care.
Why don't you go
ahead and shoot?
Go on, shoot.
Go on, go on, shoot, shoot.
I don't care.
In another couple of minutes,
I'll have the pump out.
Shut up.
It won't take very long
to put it in the other car.
I said shut up.
Look, you're going
to need that car now,
and I'm the only
one that can fix it.
I ain't waiting too long.
Judy, go get me a
soda, and that pie too.
Poor Edna.
How will anybody
be able to tell?
His son's graduation.
Doris, believe me.
I feel as badly as you.
He's dead.
Nothing can bring him back.
We're alive.
We've got to think
of ourselves now.
Do you think I wanted to
stand there and watch him die?
What could I do?
What could anyone have done?
You can't reason with that kid.
He wants blood,
Doris, and nobody's
going to talk him out of it.
Don't you understand
what we're dealing with?
He's a psycho, Doris.
Or should I have
taken his place?
Would that have made
you feel better?
What would you be saying to Carl
if it was me lying over there?
The pump's out.
All right.
Put it in the other car.
Ed, I'm sorry.
Forget it.
I feel so ashamed for
acting the way I did.
There was nothing we could do.
Why don't we just run?
The highway is only a
few yards from here.
He'd cut us down
before we got five feet.
I'll die running before
I get on my knees.
I can still see him
drinking with us.
Maybe a car will
come by and stop.
Sure, Doris.
Maybe a car will pull in.
Supposing a car does
pull in, they won't know.
He'll kill them and us too.
The police, maybe the
police will pass by.
They do patrol this highway.
They will, Ed.
They will.
Sure they will.
They'll find a way to
make them stop then.
Doris, miracles do happen,
but you can't count on them.
I'm sorry.
Now listen.
I'm going to try to find out
how many more shots he has left
or if he has reloaded or not.
But how will we find out?
Four shots we know
of, that leaves four.
He probably shot
the people here too.
There must have been two.
Remember what Carl told us about
the settings in the kitchen.
Yes.
Two plates eaten from
and two plates untouched.
Tibbs must have surprised
them while they were eating.
They were to frightened
to eat while those two
were stuffing themselves.
If he shot them, that
leaves two shots.
He certainly didn't
walk here from Arizona.
Maybe he shot someone else.
And if he hasn't reloaded--
Go ahead and talk, mister.
You talk all you want.
You thinking somebody's
going to save you.
Why should I fix the car if
you're going to kill us anyhow?
You'll fix it because
that lets you live
a little longer,
like back there.
I know that you were stalling.
If you don't want to fix
the car, you die right now.
You want this car, Tibbs.
Who are you fooling?
Oh, you can kill us,
but you'd be stranded.
That's a road, ain't it?
Where there's a
road, there's cars.
Somebody will pick us up.
They always have.
Is that how you got
here from Arizona?
A sailor picked us up.
How far did he take you?
Better than real
love, huh, Judy?
Suppose you shot him too.
Naw.
I just cut his throat.
Why haven't you
still got his car?
Ran out of gas last night.
You're sure asking a lot
of questions, mister.
But you go ahead and
ask all you want.
How did you get here?
A farmer picked us up.
His old crate broke down
up the road a piece.
Too bad.
I was beginning to
like that old codger.
Shoot him too?
He sure prayed when he
went, Judy, remember?
He reached for the sky and
talked to the Lordy Lord.
Then you shot him.
Yeah.
Right between the eyes.
What about the two
people you shot here?
Did they pray too?
You must think I'm dumb,
mister, don't know nothing.
You're counting bullets.
Count all you want.
I can count too.
You know I only fired
seven shots, only got
one bullet left
unless I reloaded.
How many bullets do I have left?
Come on, come on.
You the big man.
Come on.
The one bullet's gone.
Come on, maybe the gun's empty.
Come on, mister.
I'm giving you a chance.
Come on, big man.
Come on, mister.
Come get the gun.
What's the matter, you afraid?
You had a chance, mister.
You should have taken it.
You ain't gonna get no more.
See how yellow they are, Judy?
Afraid of an empty gun.
Big man.
Big talker.
Push her
Ed, they're getting
ready to do something.
You.
No.
The police.
they're coming, Mr. Stiles.
I told you they would.
They will stop.
They will.
They're coming after him.
They're coming after you.
You hear me?
You, you, you're not
going to kill anymore!
Doris.
Get in back.
Get in back or I'll
kill you right now.
Do as I say!
Go!
Over there.
Lie down.
Lie down!
They're stopping.
Get up.
Get to the car.
Hurry up.
It must be the police.
You get in the trunk.
Get in there or I'll
blow your brains out!
One noise and your
lady friend dies.
Keep her out of sight.
She makes one noise,
you slit her throat.
Hi.
Hello, son.
Sure a scorcher.
Sure is.
Don't recall having seen
you around here before, son.
Friend of the family.
Just talked to Milt's son
in town about an hour ago.
Funny, being the
talker he is, didn't
mention anything about visitors.
Uh, he just left
before I got in.
Lancaster, huh?
Yeah.
Been working on the car.
Fuel pump trouble.
Mine went out only last week.
You know, Jim, it cost
over $30 to get it fixed.
Boy, what a crook that guy was.
Look, somebody lost a 45 clip.
Where is Milt?
Out back someplace.
Boy, he can get more parts of a
car than the factory put in it.
Yeah, he sure can.
Help!
Help.
Get out.
I told you to keep quiet.
Should have done
what I told you.
Get moving.
Oh!
I told you
nobody could help you.
You're going to
have every officer
in California looking for you.
They don't scare me.
Nobody scares me.
I'm going to give you
a choice, big man.
You die now, or
you fix that car.
I'll give you 15
minutes to fix it.
Why should I fix it?
You'll only kill
us when I get done.
I'm giving you 15 more
minutes of life, mister.
If you don't want it, I'll
blow your head off right now.
Hers too.
It's 1 o'clock.
You got until 1:15.
You start working.
Who would ever believe
something like this?
How could he
shoot two officers?
There were two of them.
Two of them.
Judy, give me that gun.
15 minutes.
What are we going to do?
All units, all units,
be on the alert for two Arizona
murder suspects believed to be
in California, possibly driving
a green 1958 Ford sedan,
license number Mary
Nora 4-6-9-8-3.
Suspects hitched ride with the
driver of this car, a sailor
en route to San Diego.
The sailor was found murdered
two miles east of Needles
approximately 10:30 this date.
Tibbs, Charles A, male
Caucasian, age 20.
Light brown hair, blue eyes.
Height 6'1", Weight
approximately 180 pounds.
Fair complexion.
Wearing Levi jacket
pants when last seen.
This suspect is armed and to be
considered extremely dangerous.
In company with
suspect number one
is Bradshaw, Judy,
female Caucasian, age 18.
Black hair, blue eyes.
Height approximately
5'4", weight
approximately 100 pounds.
Dark complexion.
Wearing a yellow flowered
dress when last seen.
If only that radio call had
come two minutes earlier.
We've got to do something.
Looks like we'll
have to run for it.
Move closer.
Get in front of me.
I got an idea.
It may not work, but
at least it's a chance.
It's obvious he doesn't
know much about cars.
Now look, when I
get the pump in,
I'll ask you to get in
the car and start it.
Leave it in neutral.
I'll race the motor from here.
When I give you the
first signal-- uh,
I'll scratch my shoulder.
When I do, you shift into drive
and push down on the brake.
Got that?
Yes.
When I give you
the second signal--
I'll wink-- hold on tight
because I'll be pulling
the gas pedal to the floorboard.
I'm going to try to lure
him in front of the car.
Oh, Ed.
It's just a chance.
We might not hit him, but if
we can at least startle him,
it may give me the
few seconds I need.
Let's just pray this
doesn't kick out on us.
What if it does?
Run for it.
What if he won't let
me get in the car?
It's a chance we'll
just have to take.
You got 11 minutes.
Doris.
Damn it.
I can't fix the car
with you starting it.
This
is Dick Woods bringing you
music from Dodger
Stadium as we do
every Sunday preceding
the ball game.
Talking about baseball,
those red hot Cincinnati Reds
are in town, riding a
nine-game winning streak.
It's going to be Bob
Purkey going for the Reds
and Sandy Koufax
for the Dodgers.
It should be quite
a pitchers' battle.
There's still plenty of
good seats to be had,
so if you're not doing anything,
come out to Dodger Stadium
and see exciting
National League baseball.
It's a beautiful
day for a ball game.
Time is 1:10, still
time to come on down.
And now stay tuned
for Dodger warm-ups.
If we could just get them away
from the car long enough to--
Music.
All those people laughing
and yelling, so happy.
Oh Ed, I don't want to die.
I don't want to die.
You're
not going to die, Doris.
Four minutes.
Doris, get in the
car and start it
so I can see if the
pump holds pressure.
Doris, get the car and start it.
Just a minute.
You want the car to run.
I want to live those
extra few minutes.
Now I have to check
the pump for pressure.
All right.
But it better run good.
Start it up.
You ain't got much more time.
Two minutes.
How does it feel when
you're about to die?
Try it now.
I think you're yellow belly.
Yeah.
One of them squirmers.
Get out.
I said get out!
Move.
You must think I'm stupid.
You trying something?
You did something.
I did nothing.
It was running pretty
good a few seconds ago.
You must have did something.
Look, this pump has
been in a wrecked car
for who knows how long.
Now sometimes they get clogged
and don't hold a pressure.
I should take it
out and clean it.
You ain't got time for that.
It's not holding pressure.
It needs to be cleaned.
You're out of time, ain'tcha?
It won't take very long.
You ain't taking nothing out!
You think you're
fooling me, don't you?
Think I don't know nothing
about cars, don't you?
That thing right there,
that's a carburetor.
The car can't run unless
there's gas in it.
All you gotta do is prime it.
Now, I seen that
done, so you prime it.
Well, go on.
There's a gas pump over there.
Doris, get in the car and
start it when I tell you to.
Nobody gets in that car but me.
Well, if I'm going
prime it, somebody
has to pump the gas pedal.
Just never you mind.
You just put that gas
in that carburetor.
Charlie!
Oh my god, Judy!
Judy, no.
Judy.
Judy, Judy, Judy.
I
know you're hiding!
I'll find you.
I'll kill you!
Doris, run!
Purkey's out again.
Gets the sign,
wind up once more.
Ball low, outside.
A curveball just missed the
outside corner, Fairly swung.
Ball one, strike one to Fairly.
Say, incidently, there are lots
of good seats here for you fans
to enjoy the Dodgers
and the Redlegs.
If you're close by,
won't you come on down?
You'll enjoy it here at Dodger
Stadium, a gorgeous day.
Shirtsleeved crowd, everybody
having a wonderful time.
OK, we're set to go.
The bases loaded, bottom
of the first inning,
Ron Fairly up there, Purkey the
great pitcher of the Redlegs
set to go.
He faces in.
He has his sign.
There's the wind up, the pitch.
Fairly belts it.
Oh, what a smash.
SPORTCASTER (ON
Frank Robinson
is He's going
back. races
towards the wall.
Back, back, back, he goes.
Oh, it's a home run!